[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALOK GOEL: India is one
of the fastest growing
economies in the world.
Every day about 25 million
people travel
from one city to another.
A lot of those customers
actually need a last minute
travel options, and for that,
bus is one of the most
economical and flexible
options for travel.
AMULMEET SINGH: Bus travel
is also one of the most
unorganized industries, with
thousands of operators,
varying standards of services,
prices, and promises, which
makes it highly unpredictable
for a customer.
ALOK GOEL: And we decided to put
an order in this otherwise
unorganized bus ticketing
business by making it as easy
and convenient as flight booking
is, and actually went
beyond that by building an
Android app which stays with
you throughout your journey.
RAJESH BYSANI: As a bus traveler
today in the country,
there are two problems
that come to my mind.
One is, which is the bus that is
most suitable for my needs?
And how will my bus journey
experience be?
There are over a thousand
operators running over 10,000
buses in the country.
Finding a bus with a confirmed
seat is a challenging task.
Finding a bus is not enough.
You need a bus of
good quality.
ALOK GOEL: Second problem, and
also the hardest one to solve,
is that of journey experience,
and which is where Android
plays a key role.
Once you book a ticket, your
boarding point and bus is on
the map, with real-time
location update.
AMULMEET SINGH: We launched our
app two months back, and
bookings on mobile have
tripled since.
More than 70% of travel
happens last minute.
And with this app, we
are able to tap into
bookings on the go.
ALOK GOEL: Basically, we have
created a trusted travel
companion for your
next bus journey.